Dr Nash and Total Transformation who is
sponsoring this next segment have been
transforming lives all across the valley
and today we're going to look at some of
her incredible success stories
Dr Nash it is great to see you and today
is one of my favorite topics we're doing
success stories and some amazing before
and after photos and some amazing
Journeys but one of my favorite success
stories is yours once I discovered what
it was in my body that was going wrong
and adjusted and fixed it that's when
the 80 pound weight loss happened and
that's when it finally held and that's
what we do for people like we're gonna
see today yes and let's start with let's
take a look at Kimberly's success story
17 and a half pounds 26 and a half
inches the evil back fat is gone thanks
Dr Nash I loved Kimberly's energy and
the thing that she said there too the
evil back fat it's gone like that
stubborn fat you got rid of it we got
rid of it so she lost 17 pounds in 30
days which is already accelerated but
think about this JC she lost almost 27
inches off of her body in a month so
this is because we're focusing more on
Fat Loss than just weight loss so they
shrink to these incredibly small amounts
you know the inches are even better than
the fat loss but yeah beautiful
okay speaking of shrinking everybody
take a look at veto I'm Dr Nash's
program I lost 170 pounds and this is
the result
I mean I'm speechless every time I hear
Vito's story 170 pounds the guy had to
go out and buy brand new pants obviously
but what a success for Vito well Vito
was actually updated because he lost 140
pounds and then we keep in touch with
our clients and so we kept in touch with
veto and found out how's your life going
he's like I lost 30 pounds more so this
is really important not only do we help
you fix the problem that we teach you
how to fix it for good I mean he lost a
JC he did he did didn't you tell me a
story once with him and this is a great
story he was he was grocery shopping and
his pants fell down because he just lost
so much weight he went North and the
pants went South yeah
I love that that is great okay everybody
take a look at Laura's Story when I
started with Dr Nash I weighed over 300
pounds and I was pre-diabetic since
being on her program I lost over 130
pounds and I no longer have that
pre-diabetic threat Dr Nash these are
life-altering results that you're doing
here Laura's Journey just incredible
yeah and Laura's journey is similar to a
lot of older women who are blaming their
weight problem on menopause we hear that
all the time with older women she
thought it was menopause too she did
have a hormone problem but it wasn't
menopause it was dietary hormone she was
pre-diabetic when we reversed the
diabetes the weight dropped off
are these results typical for most your
clients
they are typical when you follow the
program and the protocol the way I build
it for you if you try to do it on your
own most of the time you're just not
going to get results that are this
amazing or life-changing now Dr Nash
every week you bring a great special
what do you have this week so of course
when I come on the Las Vegas now show I
want to give something special back to
the viewers normally my online
evaluations are 97 but if you say that
you saw me with JC and if you go to the
website that we're showing on the screen
I have 10 spots but only 10 available at
9.97 over 90 off let me see what's going
on in your body that's stopping you from
reaching your results and help to turn
it around